so i want to start today with something
we actually talked about on the bonus
show last week we talked on the bonus
show last week thanks to pat choosing
the story quite frankly i hadn't even
read it
which is part of the problem
joe biden has quietly almost completely
ended the drone war that has become
essentially the status quo of american
foreign policy to slightly different
degrees
since george w bush
through barack obama and including
donald trump and the corporate media has
barely mentioned it
as we were talking about it last week i
realized we really should be talking
about this more broadly there's been
this bizarre reversal on foreign policy
perspectives
for the republican party really since
donald trump started running for
president back in 2015 when suddenly
republicans
were pretending they don't like war
that they don't like military incursions
that they don't like interventionist
foreign policy when really those have
been
the hallmark of neo-conservative
republicanism for several decades at
this point in time and if you think back
it sort of started with donald trump
saying
that iraq war that was a disaster
trump started with that
and it was always bs trump's initial
political constituency was heavily made
up of people who supported the iraq war
under george w bush and admittedly
people who were sort of right-wing
reactionary
but
were not really following politics under
george w bush either because of their
age or because they just weren't paying
attention and so they bought it they
bought it hook line and sinker trump and
republicans now they're against war
um then it went to
well uh
the leftists who didn't like hillary
started building on it with the killery
stuff and the hillary's going to start
for war stuff and donald trump isn't
going to do that
that became the story
and it mostly transitioned right into
joe biden's presidency with this idea
that if you re-elect donald trump he'll
keep us out of war
but if you elect joe biden it means that
more wars are coming biden was going to
go to war i mean i don't even remember
now biden was going to go to war with
north korea
and china
and iran and russia and all this
different stuff now i said at the time i
don't see any appetite from joe biden
for doing those things maybe i'll be
proven wrong but there's another story
here that's actually what we're talking
about today
one of barack obama's biggest foreign
policy
sort of conflicts with my ideology and i
talked about this all all through the
obama administration was the drone war
trump continued the drone war massively
he didn't talk about it that much
because remember it was hillary who was
going to do the war and the bombings not
trump but trump continued barack obama's
drone war which was an escalation of
george w bush's drone war now maybe bush
would have done more if the technology
had been more mature at the time barack
obama had the benefit of that but now we
have the reality
and the reality is that joe biden has
almost completely ended the american
drone war joe biden's not really saying
that much about it the white house isn't
really saying that much about it neither
is corporate media but it's a huge
massive story
there was that one strike
during the with the afghanistan
withdrawal
which went horribly wrong killed
civilians just absolute disaster
but joe biden has almost completely
halted drone strikes and air strikes in
general
we have to call this what it is which is
a foreign policy victory in my mind and
it's also a communications and pr
failure by being almost completely
silent about it under bush we started
droning
barack obama did even more
donald trump continued
huge debate controversy but then look at
what joe biden has now done
enters office
first of all sets up a system that
requires white house approval for any
strike outside of a war zone
and listen to these numbers in donald
trump's first 11 months in office he did
1600 air and artillery strikes per air
wars which tracks drone strikes in iraq
and syria alone
air wars reports four
under joe biden's first 11 months not
400 not 40 or 40 as joe biden says just
four four of them uh strikes in somalia
down 75
from last year to fewer than 10
no civilian casualties in yemen instead
of 18
strikes last year down to four
this is a massive change
but the real question is why the biden
white house has been so quiet about it
is it because
the afghanistan airstrike the drone
strike went so wrong that they just
don't even want to talk about the fact
that there is still some droning going
on
is it because it will lead to
joe biden being called weak by
republicans which of course remember
under trump republicans claimed they are
the ones who don't want to do
intervention as foreign policy strikes
war etc but at the same time the
republican party has a long history of
pointing to democrats and saying oh you
don't want to go to war you don't want
to go to iraq you don't want to take
this person out that well then you're
actually the weak one is it a fear of
that that's keeping the biden
administration from talking about this
major accomplishment more
um is it
because joe biden doesn't like to brag i
mean there's a couple people emailed me
and said they said it's not joe biden
constitutionally joe biden doesn't like
bragging and that's why he's not doing
it he's sort of br he's bragged about
vaccines he's bragged about i don't i
don't think that that's it so a few
different things here number one
of course there's the reality that
sometimes you're droning instead of
sending in boots on the ground and this
was a big debate early in the big
campaigns under barack obama which was
well we may be using drone warfare here
instead of boots on the ground and if
either way we're going to do damage do
we prefer it be done without boots on
the ground that's not the debate now
joe biden's not talking about he
certainly doesn't seem to be thinking
about boots on the ground he's just
dramatically reduced drone airstrikes
and we should be glad about that let me
know your thoughts number one about why
you don't think it's being talked about
by the biden administration and maybe
just as importantly number two
why isn't the corporate media covering
it but they may be both related things